un mar de plástico en el cauce de este
brazo de río uno de los más contaminados
de duala vamos a vaciar el desagüe combi
como siempre el objetivo es sacar de
tres a cinco toneladas de residuos de
plástico cada semana edmon y sus colegas
recogen toneladas de estos residuos su
objetivo es reciclar las miles de
botellas artículos domésticos o
sandalias que han acabado con todo el
ecosistema de este río aquí donde
estamos No puede haber seres vivos como
peces y demás en este entorno porque las
botellas por encima del agua impiden que
la luz pase para que la vida sea posible
debajo de la superficie Así que el
objetivo principal es salvar el medio
ambiente salvar el medio ambiente y
convertir estos residuos en una ganancia
económica Este es el reto que asumió
crisma viala director de la empresa
emergente que contrata a estos
recolectores de plástico
normalmente las botellas llegan hasta
esta altura y se extienden por todo el
desagüe
a sus 38 años este informático congoleño
que vive en Camerún desde 2016
participa en el Boom de reciclaje en el
país la joven empresa de la que es
directora ha encontrado una idea
prometedora transformar estos residuos
en gránulos que servirán para fabricar
nuevos productos industriales
tenemos unas 450 personas que recolectan
plástico para nosotros lo recolectan y
nosotros lo compramos el objetivo de
todo esto es que todos nuestros
recolectores todos los que viven del
plástico puedan salir adelante a 20
kilómetros de allí se encuentra la
fábrica dirigida por crisma viala donde
cada día llegan una docena de toneladas
de residuos recogidos de todo el país
hay 0 residuos verdad
aquí comienza una segunda vida para el
plástico recolectado tras ser
clasificado y limpiado el plástico es
triturado en forma de gránulos por estas
enormes máquinas los gránulos se envasan
en estas bolsas y se exportan a Europa
para la fabricación de productos que se
distribuyen principalmente a empresas
cerveceras cada año se reciclan así 3000
toneladas de residuos
[Música]
nuestras fuentes de ingreso son las
subvenciones de estas grandes empresas
que ponen el plástico en el mercado
y también la fabricación y venta de
nuestros productos acabados
creemos que todo el mundo se implique en
los retos que plantea la contaminación
producida por el plástico
el reciclaje de plástico es un mercado
que atrae a los empresarios de la
capital económica de Camerún dado que el
precio de los materiales de construcción
Se dispara con la inflación mundial el
plástico reciclado se ha convertido en
una alternativa en el sector de la
construcción
estas Texas azules están hechas de
residuos de plástico plotteponuk
comercializa este material procesado
localmente que cuesta mucho menos que
las Tejas importadas de Turquía o Italia
esto significa 20 euros por metro
cuadrado en lugar de 28 euros por una
sola teja importada en el mercado hay
Tejas de cemento que se rompen hay Tejas
importadas de Italia que se rompen Y
tenemos estas cejas Esa es la solución
más sostenible para techos que podemos
tener es un producto para toda la vida
se coloca como las Tejas solo hay que
seguir la curva de la estructura y ya
tenemos el techo
en la fábrica que produce estas Tejas
azules un plástico pesado el polímero se
combina con arena y se calienta a 220ºc
la mezcla se moldea para fabricar un
revestimiento que podría competir con
las planchas de aluminio que todavía son
muy utilizadas
la plancha metálica ordinaria tiene una
vida útil de 30 años pero las cejas que
producimos tienen una vida útil que no
se puede medir o sea son para toda la
vida
Cuál es la ventaja del producto
tiene un aislamiento térmico Así que
debajo de estas Tejas hay una
temperatura ambiente tiene aislamiento
acústico lo que significa que cuando
llueve uno no siente el sonido de la
lluvia
mientras algunos reciclan el plástico
para fabricar materiales aislantes otros
empresarios pretenden reducir el precio
de la factura de la luz gracias a los
residuos por ejemplo haciendo un
combustible menos costoso en este
depósito Walter Jackson está probando su
último invento un combustible hecho de
plástico reciclado
gracias a esta máquina que él y su
equipo construyeron este empresario de
40 años lleva mucho tiempo trabajando en
la producción de un combustible menos
contaminante por el momento sólo produce
pequeñas cantidades Pero espera poder
ofrecerles pronto a los consumidores un
combustible más ecológico y a menor
precio hoy nos ayuda a amortizar casi el
15% de nuestro consumo de combustible un
combustible ecológico que costará unos
350 Francos cfa mientras que en la
gasolinera el mismo litro cuesta 650
Francos cfa en el futuro podremos
reducir 10.000 litros al día e incluso
más en ese momento tenemos previsto
comercializar a gran escala
Camerún produce un promedio de 600.000
toneladas de residuos plásticos al año y
aunque cada vez hay más empresas de
reciclaje solo el 20% de su residuos son
procesados